dix millions de français savoure chaque
jour son esprit bien parisien son sens
de l'humour et son ardeur au travail
suscite l'admiration de tous sains et
des trous l'alaska de philippe bouvard
dis moi finalement en toi tu es un
cynique armes saleh dans une société
d'hypocrites le cynisme fini par être le
compte de la franchise en oui est ce que
tu as déjà pensé à se suicider le
suicide c'est l'acte désespéré d'un être
qui ne fait plus confiance ni à la
guerre ni aux transports ni aux maladies
nyala nature autre chose et tu favorable
à l'abolition de la peine de mort
l'abolitionnisme c'est une mesure que on
a prises pour qu'un crime ne fasse pas
chaque fois deux bras et tu penses quoi
de l'évolution du métier de journaliste
parce que tu es journaliste tu prends
toi bouffe il aurait beaucoup à dire
mais bon faute de temps le journaliste
moderne doit choisir où voire
l'événement où le décrire il a rarement
le loisir de faire les deux
je suppose qu'ils avaient un temps tu
voulais faire la révolution
oui ben comme tous ceux qui ont 20 ans
puis après bon bah quand on s'aperçoit
qu'une révolution n'abolit pas les
privilèges mais qu'elles se bornent à
changer les privilégiés et tu penses
quoi de l'amour tarifé bas beaucoup de
bien parce que les prostituées sont des
dames qui ne demande pas qu'on les
invite à dîner avant de passer à l'acte
puis honneur à la main d'oeuvre
qualifiée
tout le monde parle de racisme mais pour
toi c'est quoi au juste le racisme basta
la fois un sentiment bas et un sentiment
en pratique puisque ça consiste à en
vouloir à des gens qui sont aisément
repérables et qui généralement sont plus
malheureux que soi
si tu devais donner une définition de la
civilisation
je dirais que selon qu'on se met un
anneau
dans néo dans l'oreille on est un
sauvage ou civilisé as tu peur de mourir
parce qu'ils m'embête c'est que la mort
empêche d'aller à ces rendez vous du
lendemain crois tu re l'existence de
dieu
non dieu n'existe pas mais enfin il faut
faire semblant d'y croire parce que ça
lui fait tellement plaisir